This lecture is about the generative
probabilistic models for text
clustering.
In this lecture we can do continue
discussing text clustering, and we're
going to introduce generative
probabilistic models as a way to do text
clustering
So this is the overall plan for
covering text clustering in the previous
lecture we have talked about what is
text clustering and why text
clustering is interesting.
In this lecture we're going to talk
about how to do text clustering, in
general, as you see on this slide,
there are two kinds of approaches.
One is generating probabilistic models,
which is the topic of this lecture, and
later will also discuss similarity
based approaches.
So to talk about generative models for
text clustering, it would be useful to
revisit the topic mining problem using
topic models.
Because the two problems are very
similar, so this is a slide that you
have seen earlier in the lecture
on topic model.
Here we show that we have input of text
collection C and number of topics K and
vocabulary V, and we hope to generate
as output two things.
One is a set of topics denoted by Theta
i's.
Each is a word distribution and the
other is a pi ij's and these are the
probabilities that each document covers
each topic.
So this is a topic coverage and it's
also visualized here on this slide you
can see that this is what we can get by
using a topic model.
Now a main difference between this and
text clustering problem is that here a
document is assumed to possibly cover
multiple topics, and indeed in general
document will be covering more than one
topic with non zero probabilities.
In text clustering, however, we only
allow a document to cover one topic.
If we assume one topic is a cluster.
So.
That means if we change the topic
definition just slightly by assuming
that each document can only be
generated by using precisely one topic.
Then we'll have a definition of the
clustering problem.
As shown here.
So here the output is changed so that
we no longer have the detailed coverage
distributions pi ij's, but instead will
have cluster assignment decisions.
An CI and CI is decision for the
document i.
And c sub i is going to take a
value from one through K to indicate
one of the K clusters.
And basically tells us document Di
is in which cluster.
As illustrated here, we no longer have
multiple topics covered in each
document is precisely one topic,
although which topic is still
uncertain.
There is also a connection with the.
Problem of mining.
One topic that we discussed earlier.
So here again it's a slide that you
have seen before.
And here we hope to estimate a topic
model or word distribution based on
precisely one document, and that's when
we assume that this document covers
precisely one topic.
But we can also consider some
variations of the problem.
For example, we can consider there are
N documents, each covers different
topic.
So that's N documents and topics.
Of course, in this case these documents
are independent and these topics also
independent.
But we can further allow these
documents share topics and then.
We can also assume that we are going to
assume there are fewer topics.
The number of documents.
So this document must share some
topics.
And if we have N documents for
share k topics, then will again have
precisely the document clustering
problem.
So because of these connections,
naturally we can think about how to use
a probabilistic generating model to
solve the problem of text clustering.
So the question now is what generating
model can be used to do clustering.
As in all cases of designing a
generative model, we hope the
generative model would adopt the output
that we hope to generate, or the
structure that we hope to model.
So in this case it's a clustering
structure.
The topics and each document that
covers one topic, and we hope to embed
such such preferences in a generative
model.
But if you think about the main
difference between this problem and the
topic model that we talked about
earlier and then you will see a main
requirement is how can we force every
document to be generated from precisely
one topic instead of K topics?
As in the topic model.
So let's revisit the topic model again
in more detail.
So this is a detailed view of two
component mixture model and when we
have K components it looks similar.
So here we see that when we generate a
document.
We generated each word independently.
And we generated each word
First make a choice between these
distributions with decided to use one
of them with probability.
So P of theta one is the probability of
choosing the distribution on the top.
Now we first make this decision
regarding which distribution should be
used to generate the world, and then
we're going to use this distribution to
sample word.
Now.
Notice that in such a generative model.
The decision on which distribution to
use for each word is independent, so
that means, for example, "the" here could
have been generated from the second
distribution.
Theta two, whereas text is more
likely generated from the first one on
the top.
That means the words in the document
could have been generated in general
from multiple distributions.
Now this is not what we want to see
for text clustering.
For document clustering where we hope
this document will be generated from
precisely one topic.
So now that means we need to modify the
model, but how well, let's first think
about why this model cannot be used for
clustering, and I just say the reason
is because.
It has allowed multiple topics to
contribute the words to the document.
And that causes confusion because we're
not going to know which cluster this
document is from an it's more
importantly, it's violating our
assumption about the partitioning of
documents in the clusters.
If we really have one topic to
correspond to one cluster of documents,
then we would have a document to be
generated from precisely one topic.
That means all the words in the
document must have been generated from
precisely one distribution, and this
is not true for such a topic model that
we're seeing here, and that's why this
cannot be used for clustering because
it did not ensure that only one
distribution has been used to generate.
All the words in one document.
So if you realize this problem, then we
can naturally design alternative
mixture model for doing clustering.
So this is what you're seeing here and
we again would have to make a decision
regarding which is distributing to use
to generate document, because the
document that could potentially be
generated from any of the K word
distributions that we have.
But this time, once we have made the
decision to choose one of the topics,
we're going to stay with this
distribution to generate the all the
words in the document.
And that means once we have made the
choice of the distribution for in
generating the first word.
We're going to stay with this
decision in generating all the other
words in the document.
So in other words, we only make the
choice once.
for all.
Basically we make the decision once for
this document and stay with this to
generate all the words.
Similarly, if I had chosen the second
distribution, theta sub two here, you
can see we will stay with this one and
then generate the entire document D.
Now, if you compare this picture with
the previous one, you will see the
desicion of.
Of using a particular distribution is
made of just once for this document.
In the case of document clustering.
But in the case of topic model we have
to make as many decisions as the number
of words in the document because for
each word we can make a potential
different decision and that's the key
difference between the two models.
But this is obviously also a mixture
model, so we can just group them
together as one box to show that this
is.
Model that will give us a probability
of a document.
Now inside this model there's also
this, which of choosing a different
distribution and we don't observe that,
so that's a mixture model.
And of course, the main problem in
document clustering is to infer.
Which distribution has been used to
generator a document and that would
allow us to recover the cluster
identity over document
So it would be useful to think about
the difference from the topic model, as
I have also mentioned multiple times.
There are many.
Two differences.
One is the choice of.
Using a particular distribution is made
just once for document clustering
model, whereas in the topic model it's
made multiple times.
Four different words.
The second is that word distribution
here is going to be used to generate
all the words for a document.
But in the case of topic modeling, one
distribution doesn't have to generate with
all the words in a document.
Multiple distribution could have been
used to generate the words in the
document.
It's also think about the special case
when one of the one of the probability of
choosing a particular distribution is
equal to 1.
Now that just means we have no
uncertainty now.
We just stick with one particular
distribution.
Now in that case, clearly we will see
this is no longer mixture model 'cause
there's no certainty here and we're
going to just use precise one of the
distributions for generating a
document, and we're going back to the
case of estimating one word
distribution based on one document.
So that's the connection that we
discussed earlier.
But now you can see more clearly.
So as more cases of using a generative
model to solve a problem, we first look
at theta and then think about how to
design the model.
But once we design model, the next step
is to write down the likelihood
function.
And after that we can do is to look at the
how to estimate the parameters.
so in this case what's the
likelihood function or it's going to be
very similar to what we have seen
before in topic models, but it will be
also different.
If you still recall what the likelihood
function looks like in PLSA, then you
realize that in general the probability
of observing a data point from mixture
model is going to be a sum over all the
possibilities of generating the data.
I in this case, so it's going to be
some over these K topics because
everyone can be used to generate the
document and then inside the sum you
can still recall what the formula looks
like an it's going to be.
A product of two probabilities and one
is the probability of choosing a
distribution.
The other is the probability of
observing a particular data point from
that distribution.
So if you are map, this formula is kind
of formula to our problem.
Here you will see the probability of
observing a document D is basically a
sum, in this case over two different
distributions.
Because we have a very simplified
situation of just two clusters.
And so in this case you can see it's a
sum of two cases.
In each case it's indeed the
probability of choosing the.
Choosing the world distribution.
Is theta one or theta two right?
And then it's this probability is
multiplied by the probability of
observing this document from this
particular distribution.
And if you further expand this
probability of observing the whole
document, we see that it's product of
observing each word X sub i.
Here we made the assumption that each
word is generated independently, so the
probability of the whole document is
just a product of the probability of
each word in the document.
So this form should be very similar to
the topic model, but it's also useful
to think about the difference and for
that purpose I am also copying the
probability of.
topic model with two components here.
So here you can see at the formula
looks very similar or in many ways they
are similar.
But there's also some difference.
And in particular, the differences on
the top you see for the mixture model,
document clustering, we first take a
product and then take a sum.
And that's corresponding to our
assumption of 1st make a choice of
choosing one distribution and then stay
with this distribution to generate all the words.
And that's why we had the product
inside the sum.
The sum corresponds to the choice.
right.
Now in the topic model, we see that the
sum is actually inside the product and
that's be cause we generated each word
independently.
And that's why we have the product
outside.
But when we generate each each word, we
have to make a decision regarding which
distribution we use.
So we have sum there for each word.
But in general, ideas are all mixture
models that we can estimate these models
by using the EM algorithm as we will
discuss more later.